what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
so as a general rule I make deadpool
videos like twice a year like I never
really do Deadpool videos any more than
that just because man I can take
Deadpool in small doses
I cannot take Deadpool a very big doses
just because of the fact that his zany
slapstick humor isn't really up my alley
it used to be but the stories had to be
interesting like Deadpool kills the
Marvel Universe or like Deadpool does it
again or something along those lines but
this is edge of venom verse and what
would an edge of that inverse story be
without Deadpool now remember when it
comes to edge of venom verse this is
much like the edge of spider-verse in
the sense that edge of spider-verse
basically culminated in the story
spider-verse itself which brought
together all these different alternate
reality versions of spiderman some of
them were spotted women in the case of
you know spider glen others were
characters that we were already familiar
with in the case of like Miles Morales
and then some were characters we'd never
seen before
an edge of spider-verse was just like
these series of one shots that just gave
us these you know stories it was like
two or three stories in one anyway just
give us these stories on these different
characters these different iterations
different things like that with edge of
venom verse is these alternate reality
stories about people who became venom
noah deadpool it kind of makes sense
because this is not a one-off right it's
not like the very first time deadpool
ever became venom he's been venom as far
as i'm aware on two other occasions the
first one was a what-if story called
what if deadpool became venom and then
another one was a Deadpool back in black
I think it was but the funny thing about
that is that it treats them all as if
they're in continuity and all this
actually goes back to 1984 Secret Wars
when Marvel launched the original secret
war story in the 2015 relaunch Marvel
also published a story called Deadpool
secret secret war which basically
revealed he was the reason why I like
everything happened it was it was crazy
he was ready there was kind of a bunker
story but in this instance this is one
of those things where it's like Marvel
Maxim Punisher right like well one thing
I want to clear up a lot of you guys
asked me if I would do more Punisher max
a YouTube d monetize that putter should
match the video immediately after it
came out so and the story's only get
more brutal from there so I mean I'd
love to you but like literally YouTube's
gonna do monetize it as soon as it goes
up so that kind of sucks middle we could
find a way around it I'm not sure but
the idea here is that with Deadpool in
this story we don't really see any other
superheroes and that's kind of the cool
thing because remember the edge of the
numbers stories are designed to focus
almost exclusively on the character at
hand and that's the way it's been with
all the other stories that we've seen so
far
x-23 and so on and so forth the focus
has been on the end
character and so in this instance I mean
as a Deadpool stories was crazy what is
basically that like some scientists
discovered like this prehistoric
tapeworm and like the poop of a shark
which doesn't make any sense because as
far as I'm aware shark poop does not
fossilize I could be wrong but I don't
think it does and even if it did the
water would probably keep it from
fossilized but the fact remains here
we're not getting into like the the
physics of poop
the whole idea here is that this whole
experimentation with this tapeworm
coincides the guy named dr. Scott now
dr. Scott is basically this guy who
grabbed these tapeworms and then try to
find a way to weaponize them which makes
sense because I mean this tapeworms and
as a bad guy why wouldn't he do that ah
the problem here is that it all
basically ran amok as you would expect
it to in this kind of circumstance now
this is where things get kind of cool
right like when it comes to Deadpool
stories depending on what story you're
reading and what story's going on as I
understand it from what video where
comic story has been telling me the
current run of Deadpool and all-new
all-different marvel it's like nothing
short of spectacular which I should
probably check it out but if you go back
and read some of the older Deadpool
stories they're just sort of all over
the place like they're absolutely
bonkers I mean given his history it kind
of makes sense you know Joe Kelly was
the one that started making him a funny
character Christopher priest is the guy
that made him break the fourth wall all
the time and then different riders just
kind of kept that trend going but when
it comes to Deadpool the story usually
get pretty bonkers and pretty zany and
there's instance he's actually just kind
of fighting tapeworms that have taken
over a human host and the idea is that
they you know every time Deadpool
decapitates these guys these tapeworms
just kind of reconstruct their body
again the other half of this is that
these tapeworms are sentient and so
they're literally going through and
trying to take over different people now
this is when we start to get into the
influence of like Deadpool secret secret
Wars and like what if Deadpool became
venom different things like that because
in those stories it's usually the idea
that Deadpool either the Venom's thrust
upon him by somebody who already has it
in the case of like spider-man or he
simply just discovers it now in Deadpool
secret secret war it was totally
different in the original secret war
story which this is kind of cool I think
he has a big this and the original
secret war story spider-man was hunting
around like this base looking for a suit
or looking for looking for a new change
of clothes and had discovered the Venom
symbiote not realizing what it was it
bonded itself to him and he was like
holy cow I have like new abilities it's
like a new suit it wasn't until he got
back to earth that he realized that the
suit was basically sentient man Reed
Richards helped him get rid of it and
Deadpool secrecy grrrrrr war
Spider Man actually stops Deadpool
asking if he if he knows we're like
a change of clothes and like Deadpool's
like yeah they're right over there and
sends them over to the venomous India so
it's kind of funny like Deadpool is the
reason why Spiderman became venom but
the fact remains of course once Deadpool
bonds with a symbiote what this does is
it kind of hints at the idea that he's
had it before now it just comes through
like song lurks right you know he's like
I've come to bond with you again you
know that kind of a thing it makes sense
I mean assuming that like everything in
this story in this alternate reality
followed exactly the way things have
been up until this moment or even if it
takes place just in some you know in the
main Marvel Universe which it entirely
could just because of how things are
unfolding but if it occurred in the main
Marvel Universe it would stand to reason
that like Deadpool's been venom before
and so it makes sense he's bonded with a
symbiote on you know on several
occasions but regardless of the logic
behind it using the Venom symbiote he
basically just like starts taking every
last one of these out and just crushing
and now of course this reveals to us as
the reader that over the course of their
attempts to weaponize these tapeworms
they've actually been implanting them in
the bodies of human people now this is
not something the scientists have been
doing willingly this was done by the
scientist who were taken over by these
little you know tapeworm symbiotes or a
tapeworm parasite so of course they're
basically kind of forced into it it's
for your mother for the most part like
your standard fare with like Body
Snatchers basically like invasion of the
Body Snatchers not the old one that
sucks the good one with Donald
Sutherland like that's that's that's
what I'm talking about it's basically
some people are taken over by aliens
they start taking more people over by
aliens and you know different things
like that it follows the exact same
formula I mean it's pretty
straightforward and really where it goes
from here is just dead forest crushing
all the different aliens and taking him
out of course being attacked on his own
different things like that and fighting
all these different you know people and
these different doctors and so on and so
forth who have been possessed by these
parasites but he creates somewhat of a
strange situation because again when it
comes to Deadpool as characters waxed
and waned so much over the years
different writers write him different
ways there have been stories where there
just like Deadpool doesn't care who he
kills he'll just kill whoever he needs
to in order to like take out whoever it
is that he's tracking but there are
other writers who write him in a way
worse like Deadpool's got a moral
compass or Deadpool's like yeah I mean
I'm goofy I'm zany I'm an assassin you
know when I go for a target they can't
stop me but like I'm not gonna kill an
innocent person because I don't need to
so recruits one of these these cool
situations because we can kind of grab
either one I mean in this instance
they're attacking him and they're kind
of overwhelming him but their patience
they're not doctors so it's not like
they're the ones who were who started
all this they're the ones who were
basically victims of all this so it very
much falls in line with the idea of
Deadpool trying to take these guys out
really without trying to get to you know
to twine up about it now of course once
these tapeworms basically infest
Deadpool there's suddenly like taken
over like they're basically obliterated
by the Venom symbiote and so what the
Venom's to be it does is use these
tapeworms start coughing them all out
and then again just go through the
process or just you know tearing them
all up so again it's a Deadpool story
it's pretty straightforward I mean
there's really not a whole lot of room
for a like here's what Deadpool thinking
about the circumstance he's in you know
is I mean I'm it seems like he's
enjoying it for the most part but then
what comes after this is that with a
story being relatively serious so far it
again kind of breaks off into that whole
idea of a getting zany and getting silly
so like once these parasites are taking
taken out like he's running around like
delivering kids he's making like balloon
puppets with like these these tapeworms
but of course this leads directly into
the events of edge of the diverse proper
which is to say minimize Captain America
running around to these different
realities and grabbing these different
characters who have become venom and
then inducting them into whatever group
it is that he's forming for the purpose
of doing whatever it is that they're
gonna do we don't know the answer to
that we have no idea how things are
gonna transpire we have to wait for the
story to actually start but again it's
pretty cool because it's just some of
these little one shots just these little
stories or we see characters and
situations that we wouldn't normally see
them in and so it gives us this cool
little you know indication of you know
how this Deadpool is venom differs from
the other Deadpool's as venom because
and the other story and the what-if
story where Deadpool became venom he was
like an 80s guy like he had like oh my
god there's this moment where he gets
the Venom symbiote and the finem venom
to me it takes the form of jheri curl
he's got jheri curl Deadpool has jheri
curl and it's amazing it's so awesome
the fact remains you know it's it's kind
of a cool story pretty little you know
interesting situation but in any event
if you guys are new here to comics
explain to make sure you guys hit the
sub button to become part of the Rob
port if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah pretty
fungible story and I'll catch you all
later peace
[Music]